this whole like school thing is not for
me
because if i can't shove a broom up
somebody's asked i just don't belong
here
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
almost failer of algebra one and former
teenager elise morales
and with us today we have the incredibly
funny the incredibly talented
actress comedian and host of the devil's
advocate podcast
and former langley high school
student please welcome rosebud baker
so i usually kick off the podcast by
asking
whether or not a person's high school
was public or private but i
already know the answer for you because
langley high school
was a part of the fairfax county public
school system and i
am also an fcps girl yeah
yeah it's crazy i uh it's so funny every
time i meet someone
from virginia or who grew up in our area
it's like
i you can't recognize it like it's not
like something where you can be like oh
i can tell this person's from but then
after they say it you're like
then you can see it for some reason you
know
there's no like active like accent
or like culture to fairfax county
but once once someone identifies
yourself like themselves it's like ah
it's a fairfax county girl i get it
right i get it i can see it
yes she has friends whose parents
won't tell you what they do for a living
that's like
the dna area she has friends who got
cars for their 16th birthday for sure
even if she didn't absolutely
i um i did not get a car for my 16th
birthday but i did my parents did
eventually buy me a car and they got me
a
pt cruiser oh nice
you're like a drummer you just put your
drum set in the back and i had
like i i had to act like i was jazzed
about it
because i'm not i'm not such an
ungrateful teen that i'm not gonna
be happy that my parents got me a car
but it does have a pt cruiser has an
anal
like an analog clock inside like it has
no digital clock so you have to just
like run an actual clock
i used it to my advantage by i parked in
visitor parking my senior year all year
because everyone just assumed
with my car that said like cougar
theater that i was just a parent
and i was able to do that all year
without paying for parking so that's
amazing
it's so funny too because it's like your
parents buy you a car they go to this
like
massive length to get you a car and then
you're like okay this is the one car
that everyone
is making fun of like you guys screwed
me
like this is like you're it's a car but
it also you might as well
well right like [ __ ] you on the window
shield you know
did you have a car in high school
i did i had a it was a car that my dad
bought for my mom
and then i ended up driving it uh but it
was like an accord it was a honda accord
and i loved it i felt like accords were
like the camel lights
of cars like it reminded me of like a
box of camel lights it was
neutral it was just like a neutral car
it was not it didn't draw a lot of
attention it wasn't very showy and it
wasn't like
i just liked it it was like a utility
vehicle that didn't make me
look like i was spoiled which was like
important
to me at the time and were you were you
that friend who drove everybody around
or were you did you was that like a
different person in the group
nobody wanted to be in a car with me i
was a horrible driver
within six months of getting of like
getting the rights to drive that car
i had my license taken away for reckless
driving
because i truly would speed everywhere i
thought of cars
like i genuinely thought i was
absolutely uh
like i couldn't die and i would take
these cars you know
in virginia there's like these big
winding roads especially in like great
falls and mclean area
yeah and i would try to get air in my
car
like i was in a bumper car yes
my buddy chelsea had like a race car
basically and we would do the same thing
on those like
back roads that we would take to get to
high school and we would literally try
to
like take off over the hill yeah yeah it
was like
major i was like a majorly insane
person um but no i never drove anybody
around nobody wanted to be in the car
with me
i did have to drive my sisters around a
lot um
which was crazy of my parents to be like
okay she can't drive she literally can't
drive
let's put our other kids in the car with
her and see what happens
was your reckless behavior mostly
confined to
your vehicle or were you like wild in
all
aspects of your life no i was pretty
much wild in all aspects i
i i could not be contained i was just a
reckless little
railroad kid is like that was like my
vibe you know and it's so funny because
when you're growing up
in uh fairfax county and in virginia
you know that like that area is full of
a bunch of
like diplomats sons and daughters and so
they're spoiled they're spoiled kids and
they
are um and some of them really look up
to their parents and then the other half
end up becoming comedians and um
or like a high number of comedians from
fairfax county virginia yeah and uh
and it's if you look at it like the way
that i was back then
i i just couldn't i was reckless in all
aspects i
um i loved drugs i loved drinking i
loved um
i loved like older guys i loved sneaking
out of the house
i loved um tulle and
311 and um
fish i couldn't decide what kind of
music i liked i mean it was really all
over the place i loved the roots
um most deaf black star i i was like all
over i was just
seeking some sort of identity that was
as far from where we were from
as possible yeah it does seem like all
the bands you chose are
ones that have like very intense
followings like you wanted to be a fan
of something
that had like a fandom it seems yeah
if there's anyone that i could say i was
a real fan of it was the roots because
that's lasted through
my adulthood like i still listen to
their roots constantly
but yeah i really loved the fandom i
loved going to concerts i loved getting
[ __ ] up at concerts that was like my
main thing i'm sober now and i
cannot go to a concert like it's like
i've been sober for so long
if i go to a concert i'm like i gotta
get [ __ ] up like it's
it's crazy like awakens a beast in me do
you remember the first
concert that you got like really [ __ ]
up at
um i blacked out for a lot of them but i
do remember
catching i remember my hair catching on
fire when i went to see the roots
um at the night at uh was it the 9 11
club
9 30 club oh yeah okay that's better
yeah i've been i've been to the
9 30 club also as a youth but i was too
i just remember 9 11 because my hair
caught on fire
that's all you know the 9 11 club
imagine you opening up a [ __ ] music
video and you're like
this is this isn't asking for it this is
fine
no the 9 30 club is famous though i also
went to the auto bar
did you ever go to the auto bar that was
in baltimore
yeah i went to the auto bar but i can't
remember what it looked like
like i i know the name so well oh no you
know what i did i went to
i did comedy at the auto bar that's
where ow
that's what i went through i would go to
see a it was
a space themed rockabilly band
called the phenomenon
yeah say that again space themed
rockabilly band okay i don't know which
part of that you're not
processing it
there's just a lot of missing okay they
had a tour bus that they
designed to look like a little spaceship
and i was obsessed with them i brought
them
a build-a-bear that i made at the
fairfax uh
at the fair oaks mall oh my god
i brought them an original fair oaks
mall build-a-bear
and presented it to them that's the
greatest gift
it was beautiful and i was i was
dedicated to them they were
cute they all had like stage personas of
different like aliens and stuff i was
really into it
yeah i remember going was it um
i can't remember if it was like string
cheese or
it was some kind of like jam band kind
of like
wannabe jam band uh but i remember
getting a backstage pass and then
bringing the lead
singer to my home in virginia
where my mom was sleeping upstairs and
this man
i [ __ ] you not was in his 40s
and came to my house like
and we never hooked up but i like i
don't know what i was thinking
like i absolutely like he thought
he was gonna [ __ ] a teenager and yeah
he was 40. so what was
like teen rosebud were you did you have
extracurriculars you were involved in or
was it all like
bands partying rock chick life
so when i got into high school i was a
cheerleader and
uh it was mainly because they my parents
wanted me to do a sport and i was like
there's no way
um i was a dancer and i would like dance
about i would dance every day i would go
to ballet class
and i would and i took it really
seriously like i was
good and i and i practiced constantly it
was like by the end of high school it
was like
five to six days a week and so the only
way that i
was able to kind of like think of a
sport that mimicked that was like
being a cheerleader and um about
four weeks into cheerleading i got
benched which
i didn't know was possible yeah on a
cheerleading squad yeah you can get
benched you can be a cheerleader who's
sitting on the bench
like like as if you have an injury but
the reason i got benched was because i
made a joke
i roasted one of the other cheerleaders
um
and it it did not land uh i did not have
the skill set
um and it just came off as anti-semitic
and
i was benched and i um
so and then i realized like around this
time
i was uh i started to smoke weed and i
was like oh it's cool
that i'm benched as a cheerleader i
don't want to be a part of this
i want to be on the edges of of society
right yeah i'm already getting this vibe
uh like eliza dushku and bring it on
like she has that little speech where
she's like your school has no gymnastics
team this is a last resort
and then she's the mean cheerleader it
was just like that
and i was um so i just decided okay
i'll do this and um and then i got
benched so many times that i
had to i just decided to stop i just was
like [ __ ] it i'm not gonna do this
anymore
i'll i'll do um i'll do an
extracurricular some other way
but the only extracurricular there was
was smoking weed for me
and i just would go to a friend's place
smoke weed every day
i loved bands i loved partying it was
all that for the rest of high school
and did you get involved in any like
performance i mean you were dancing but
anything that like hinted at your future
in comedy was that going on when you
were a teen
yeah so i wasn't i loved acting from
like the time that i was like
10 i like even younger like i was like
putting on plays for my family and [ __ ]
so
when i but i didn't want to be a nerd
like i didn't want to be popular but i
didn't want to be a nerd
so i did this thing where we left i
could leave in the middle of
school um i did all my like
like history science math english and
then i would leave for the second half
of the day and i would go
to this um like
academy it was called uh fairfax academy
yes
okay i remember i always wanted to do
those classes because you got to leave
yeah so i left and i would go do fairfax
academy and i would go
do these acting classes in the afternoon
and then i'd come back at the end of
school and meet up with everybody and go
smoke weed
so you did the acting classes but were
you were you involved in the plays at
your school or were you just like
no i'm just studying the craft right now
yeah
no i was like no i'm just i'm i'm
dedicating myself to the craft i'm not
here for the applause
i just want to learn it and i
it's so funny that i even got into like
like when i went
to emerson i they were like what plays
have you done and i was like oh
and then at the very end of senior year
i was like i got to do a play
because otherwise i'm not going to get
into emerson so i did the wizard of oz
and they cast me
as the wizard i was
they were like she's got a real booming
voice and they like
they put me in the back behind a curtain
and i was like
i thought i was going to get dorothy for
sure and they were like
no not with that set of pipes like get
back there
and we'll put you on the god mic and
that's it
but um so yeah that was the only play
that i did and it was the last
year of uh high school that i mean the
parallels are endless because my big
play that i did in high school was also
the wizard of oz but i was glinda
so i go see god damn
i snagged that and we had a flying
machine i flew around it was crazy
i can see that for you i can see you as
glenda thank you
there was actually well during the show
like they originally cast it and there
was an a
cast that was and then we had under
studies but then the drama teacher
decided that the understudies had been
doing such a good job that he gave them
an extra performance and i had a
full-on mental breakdown
i was like so now the understudies are
performing the sunday matinee
well i'm just so they're clear the
understudies are doing the sunday
matinee like i just started freaking out
you're like so nobody ran this by me
nobody talked
to me yeah like okay i guess
beating the lead means nothing
i love that i can see that so panicked
um do you remember kind of going off of
that
do you remember any of like your major
high school dramas like what was
like a time that you just really freaked
out
in school over something um
oh god this is like this is the only
this is so bad i don't even know if i
can share this but like
it was um i remember being in uh
in science class and the teacher
accusing me of selling drugs um
they it was like she she went to my mom
and she was like
uh your daughter's selling drugs and i
was like i'm not selling drugs i was
like i don't even know how to sell drugs
like
there's no i i can't i wouldn't know
where to get that i would literally
probably
drive through dc asking people does
anyone have drugs i can sell
like i don't know and my mom was like i
know you don't know this [ __ ] like
hates you
i don't know why she calls me every week
like this teacher had like a real
problem with me and i don't know what it
was
i still to this day believe that it was
like a repressed homosexual
urge that she was feeling and pedophilic
maybe a little bit and like i
hate this teacher to this day and she
because she called my mom and she my mom
was freaking out she was like oh my god
like
bud's selling drugs and i had to like
sit her down and explain to her
how incapable i was of doing that
and then finally my mom like went in and
just chewed this teacher up like chewed
her up
and spit her out to the point where the
teacher was like crying
and my mom was like you're jealous of my
daughter
yeah did she ever say
what it was that made her think that or
what put her down that path or she just
was like
you got it she was just selling vibe
yeah she was just like your daughter's
bad news she's just
bad news bears she comes in every week
with these short skirts and my mom's
like that's her cheerleading uniform she
has to she's like required to wear that
and she's like well she's hanging out
with bad people and and i always see her
with her
with her junior boyfriend and like she
just
hated me hello
everyone today's episode of the roast of
your teenage self podcast is brought to
you by
trivia star do you enjoy challenging
yourself with trivia
of course you do if you're the one who
always knows the answer test your
knowledge with
trivia star trivia star is a free
mobile quiz game that is entertaining
and challenging you can choose from
categories like music sports movies tv
animals celebrities there there's a ton
of categories there's over 60
categories to choose from so there's
always
more trivia to explore maybe
one day in the future trivia nights will
come back
you can play trivia star all the way
through
the rest of the pandemic and then when
trivia nights come back
you lead your team to victory i'm just
spit falling here
trivia star has two thousand five star
reviews in the apple store so join them
today and see
if you're smart enough to win if you're
listening to this podcast i know you're
basically a genius
so why don't you get on trivia star and
prove it right now trivia star
is offering you 2 500 coins and 500 gems
you can use those to play
etc when you download and play
just go to the apple or google store and
search trivia star
again search trivia star and enjoy
500 coins and 500 gems download trivia
star
for free today
wow it's so funny how people who wrong
you at that time it like really sticks
with you like i also had a teacher who
was just kind of like
irrationally a jerk to me and in my mind
what i have decided is that
he was going through a divorce and i
reminded him of his wife
that's what i decided at the time
basically absolutely nothing and it is
what i continue to believe to this day
you probably weren't that wrong honestly
because it's a very mature
thought for a high schooler to have it's
got a lot of insight in it
and i think that that message came from
your higher self
truly like there's not a doubt in my
mind about it and it's really not based
on anything other than
like yeah this cosmic understanding of
like
this is coming from somewhere a deep
pain within
my philosophy teacher right you're like
and it's it's got a lot of empathy in it
you know
and it is i understand that it is
strange at the time
when you're a teenager because it's this
weird place where like you are
not an adult but you know that you're
close
and but but adults in your life still
have this like mystery around them where
you think you assume they have their
[ __ ] together and you assume
kind of the best about them no yeah but
it's also like
i feel like at that time that whole
image of my parents was like starting to
crumble
like i was like my when because in
eighth grade my mom got into like a
drunk driving accident while i was there
and like she went into aaa and got sober
and but she'd spent a night in jail
and like my dad and her didn't get along
and he was sleeping on the couch all the
time so i was starting to see
okay these are two people that do not
belong together but they have five
children
and they don't know what to do so like
i think i was just kind of reacting the
entire time that i was in high school to
that
to that feeling that i was getting from
my parents that they
were no longer like the icons that i
thought they were
as a child not that i ever like super
looked up to my parents
but you know you're a kid you almost
like in your mind
they're like god to you yes yeah
and it's actually funny so i think we
have we have a picture of you as a
child which i think i want to pull up
and then compare to one of the pictures
we have of you
in your late teens okay so we're going
i just look like a [ __ ] butterball
turkey i love this picture
this is um you i i really i i hate to
say it but you look like honey boo-boo
a hundred percent i look like i'm about
to eat
my sister i look like once the once they
take the photo i'm gonna
eat her arm honey boo boo holding baby
boo boo
and it's like so cute yeah it's
wow so this is like a very incredibly
angelic image uh and then we can
fast forward what 10 years to this next
one
and here yeah yeah this is uh
well it's definitely more than 10 years
yeah i was like i'm not sure
where exactly after this was after i
graduated high school
okay this was when my alcoholism was in
full swing i was um
i was cutting my own hair with knives
my parents had gotten divorced my s one
of my sisters passed away
my senior year of high school like right
before i graduated
and then i went to europe and i this was
me
this was me and uh just in terms of like
my skills for dealing with trauma where
this is it you're looking out yeah you
do appear to be smoking
inside is it a transport an airport
yeah that's an airport you are smoking
inside an airport you have aviators on
holding off i was told after the picture
was taken that smoking was illegal in
this airport i remember that
because i i just assumed while we're in
europe you can smoke in an airport here
and uh that wasn't the case they were
like no you
you're the only one smoking right now
and uh
why the aviators i don't unders i don't
know i guess i just wanted to get in the
mood to fly a plane
yeah i mean it was a full it was a full
look that you're providing
you wanted to let people know what you
were about and i think this
does it have you shown people either of
these photos
and you were like yeah she's from
fairfax county they'd be like no she's
not that's
that's the cousin that lindsay lohan is
embarrassed of
like yeah good god just
i like you would guess that i was raised
under a railroad
[Laughter]
it's horrible either one of those photos
what 100 um
so okay do you remember any
like big scandals from
your high school like uh one one example
that i use is that at my high school
there was a big
scandal i remember getting on the bus
and everybody on the bus was all a
twitter because
this girl had put a remote control in
her butt at a party over the weekend
yeah big deal oh it was a huge deal
an enormous deal so do you remember any
of the like weird
rumors or like crazy pranks or
happenings like that
yeah i remember um a huge
well i remember one big deal was when i
was um i was actually
suspended for uh
sexual harassment i had
i shoved a broom up my friend's ass
i i was pretending to like i grabbed a
broom and i
sh and i like poked his [ __ ] with it
while he was getting
like stuff out of his locker and
somebody saw me and they were like that
sexual harassment you're getting
um you're getting suspended that might
have been a middle school actually
but uh yeah it was a big deal and
um i got in a lot of trouble for that uh
were you like when that happened
were you just like shocked by it were
you scared
like no i was just like are you [ __ ]
serious
like and i reacted it's so funny because
now
uh if you look at it i totally reacted
like someone who's guilty of sexual
assault like i was like
what that
it was a joke it was happening it was a
[ __ ] joke
okay he was laughing the whole time
laughter means yes okay like i was
fully um but i i remember
like truly thinking this
whole like school thing is not for me
like i was like i think i just don't
belong in a school
because if i can't shove a broom up
somebody's asked i just don't belong
here
like dude what was your parents reaction
to it like did they also think it was
kind of dumb or were they
mad at you for getting in trouble i
don't even know if they were paying
attention
honestly they had so many kids my mom
was pregnant from the time i was like
born until i was 10. so
and the last the last batch were twins
so it was really just like she had so
many kids
and she was so busy with them and um
i you could kind of get a sexual
harassment charge and it would fly under
the
it really would it wasn't even a big
deal in my house
my you know and i think my mom was uh at
the end of her drinking at that time too
so a lot of [ __ ] just went just got
brushed under the rug because it's like
she forgot and what your friend
thought at the time like he was laughing
i mean he was like this is ridiculous
like it's not like it actually went in
i assume he's wearing pants and clothes
and all that stuff
sure was sure was um i remember so much
stuff like that especially
from middle school and like
like like issues where something that
was clearly a joke among friends would
get taken
so far out of context and just feeling
like the adults around me were so absurd
and ridiculous
for like yeah i think um
but everything that they did was like
absurd and ridiculous and if i look at
it now
and i'm like if i had a kid that was
doing stuff like like
shoving a broom up somebody like
literally just like
poking somebody's [ __ ] with a broom
your friend
i as a parent i'd be like okay that's
just funny that's just you
just being funny okay but if like
you know most of the stuff i feel like
that they were reacting to
now i look at and i'm like yeah they
absolutely should have
reacted to that yeah i mean i definitely
think it's
merits a conversation with the student
of like
we leave [ __ ] related stuff we do
that in a separate space we leave that
out yeah this classroom
yeah it's not for school days okay it's
not gonna be something you can do at
work
later on just get the message you know
yeah
we're creating a we're trying to create
a semi-professional environment here and
for that reason you cannot poke your
friend in the [ __ ]
with the janitor's broom yeah
also this isn't yours like you don't
yeah none of these things are yours
to touch
okay that's amazing um i think
that we are rounding out on the end so
i like to i like to always end by asking
you
um if you could speak to your teenage
self
today what would you tell her what
advice would you give her
oh wow that's a really good question i
think
i think i'd probably tell her like hey
you don't have to like be anybody
like you don't have to dress
as something to look like someone that
you're not
and just if whatever it is about you
that's embarrassing
just embrace it and just be that
embarrassing thing
and like back yourself up because
if anything i i look back everything
that happened to me that was
embarrassing in high school
was the direct result of me trying
to look cool or
trying to hide how embarrassing i
actually was
yes yeah yeah it's all the posturing
that is actually embarrassing like the
stuff that
i you know wanted to
hide about myself about how like anxious
and however
i felt you know how not cool i felt is
way less embarrassing than like
the times i pretended to be drunk at
parties
and obviously was pretending like
that is so funny oh my god
[ __ ] pretending to be drunk is so
funny and such a high school move
like yeah i remember actually being
drunk and pretending to throw up
like just trying so hard to like
be involved in like other people's
experiences and
relate to other people because you just
feel like such a [ __ ] weirdo
yeah and you're like well man like yeah
i'm crazy
like yeah i'm like i'm the crazy fun one
like everybody sees on tv and then it's
like no you're just
a 15 year old pretending to be drunk in
a finished basement
yes oh my god absolutely well roseman it
was
amazing to have you on the show thank
you so much absolutely
it was so fun to do it yeah
thank you so much of course and shout
out to the fairfax county public schools
for bringing us this episode um
and for everybody at home this has been
the roast of your teenage self podcast
you